in 1948 when the mass expulsion of
palestinians from their homes by what
would become known as the state of
israel took place some 28 of those
families came here to the sheikh gerard
neighborhood of east jerusalem in 1956.
they settled here hoping that this would
be the last time they would lose their
homes
since then they've faced a constant
struggle to stay in shekjara
forced evictions by the state of israel
and jewish settler violence against them
have made life unbearable
um samir tends to her garden telling us
with the support of palestinians all
around the world she summons the
strength to stay here despite what she
faces
they harass our family and pitas they
don't care my grandson 14 years old was
standing in front of the main gate of
the house they came and took him
his father defended him a lot of
problems like that we have in this
neighborhood the settlers attack the
houses trying to prove their rights in
this way it's a type of terrorism and
trying to scare people in 1956 east
jerusalem was under jordanian rule in
sheikh jarrah jordan provided the land
and the united nations provided money to
build the homes
back in 1950 israel and jordan signed a
treaty dividing jerusalem
in 1967 israel violated that treaty and
occupied east jerusalem israel then
claimed under its control all previous
agreements were null and void under
international law israel has no legal
authority over the population it
occupies a fact it routinely ignores in
1972 jewish organizations claim they own
the houses the palestinian families
lived in
after a hard-fought legal battle
courts awarded ownership to israeli
illegal settlement organizations since
then more decades-long legal battles
have forced the evictions of palestinian
families
international outcry led to protests
across palestine and the world which
turned violent in early summer of 2021.
israel then bombed gaza in may of that
year as hamas which runs the strip
showed solidarity with the remaining
residents of sheikh jarrah the head of a
palestinian think tank says the issue of
sheikh jarrah is much deeper is the
question of control
the question of claimed sovereignty and
they have been crushing the palestinian
presence in jerusalem since 1967. you go
for record all the time now very
recently they come with this idea about
law registration ownership what is what
is not work all these claims are not
used for the legal perspective it is
only for ownership and control some 300
palestinians are under threat of forced
evictions
in march 2021 the israeli courts ruled
that four families could stay in their
homes
pending a land arrangement effectively
that's a state of execution it means
that all previous legal decisions are
null and void and those families can
argue their case but for the rest of the
families under threat of forced eviction
their situation remains precarious
but even then the final arbiter of that
ruling is an israeli office within the
ministry of justice for the four
families their past experience with the
israeli courts suggests future decisions
might not be in their favor but for them
and other palestinians who still face
forced evictions
they say support at home and abroad
gives them the strength they need to
remain and fight for the right to live
in their own homes
now sami this is just one particular
neighborhood we're talking about in
occupied east jerusalem this is actually
happening happening in several different
neighborhoods in salan
and other neighborhoods it is a legal
fight that's what the israelis say they
look they say the israeli government
says look it's up to the law courts this
is something that we do but if you speak
to palestinians firstly there is no uh
hope in uh or belief that the law courts
are going to offer a fair uh or at least
even a uh a fair hearing to them and
listen to their arguments and the
evidence that they produce
so we have a lot of organizations here
in occupied east jerusalem that are
fighting for the rights of the
palestinians but israel keeps changing
the laws israel keeps raising the bar
and oftentimes these are backed uh uh
those cases are backed by jewish
settlement organizations who have a lot
more money to spend who have a lot more
lawyers and so the fact that the
israelis say well actually it's up to
the law courts the palestinians aren't
playing on any sort of level playing
field